[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في هذه التغطيه
المستمره من العربيه لليوم الثالث على
التوالي لكارثه الزلزال الذي ضرب تركيا او
سوريا اذا اكثر من ثلاثه عشر الفا هو رقم
القتلى في البلدين حتى الان وبعد شكاوى
عديده في سوريا من عدم وصول المساعدات اكد
وزير الخارجيه التركي ان العمل جار على
فتح معبرين مع سوريا لايصال هذه المساعدات
وشاحنات محمله بالمواد الاغاثيه حتى قبل
الزلزال كانت قد وصلت الى باب الهوى وحتى
الان علق هناك هذا قبل الزلزال
وتضرر الطريق ولم تعرف هذه الشاحنات
الوصول الان نحن نامل انه مع غدا او يعني
على الاقصى يوم الجمعه صباحا سيكون هذا
الطريق قد اصلح
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ابويا هلا طالعنا
امي واخته
[تصفيق]
يلا
الله اكبر
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اهلا بك جمعه ماذا عن جهود الانقاذ حيث
تتواجد واخر ارقام القتلى حتى الساعه
يعني جهود الانقاذ تسير بوثيره متسارعه
عما كانت عليه خلال الليلتين الماضيتين
رغم يعني البلد وظروف الصعبه والاعياء
الذي اصاب جميع الفرق في كل المدن الا ان
يعني الخطى تتسارع وتسابق زمن للبحث عن
ناجين من تحت الانفاق خلال الساعات
الماضيه تم انقاذ ثلاثه اشخاص وهو يعني
يعني بعض من الامل في نفوس فرق الانقاذ
والاهالي الذين يترقبون اي اخبار عن
اقاربهم ومحبهم داخل المباني
المنهاره يعني عمليات ازاله الانقاظ
والبحث عن ناجين توقفت وانتهت في مدينه
حماه تشارف على الانتهاء في مدينه
جبله
يتسارع بينما يتسارع الخطى في مدينه
اللاذقيه وايضا في ريف
الجنوبي وايضا قريب في مدينه حلب فيما
تتجه بشكل لافت الى بلدتي جنديرس التي
يتسع فيها نطاق البحث عن احياء لان مدينه
جنديرس هي الاكثر تضررا على مستوى سوريا
84 مبنى على الارض جهودا لانقاذ شملت حتى
الان 22 مبنى وهناك اصوات تصنع من المباني
المجاوره اي ان فرق الانقاذ كلما تقترب من
مبنى يسمى اصوات من مباني اخرى ما يؤكد ان
هناك الجهه الانسانيه العامله في جنديرس
تحديدا لانه كما ذكرت هي الاكثر تضررا
شخص تم انتشالهم من تحت الانقاض بحاله
صحيه متفاوته بعض المصاب بجروح بليغه
وبعضهم بجروح طفيفه والمرصد السوري باخر
تحديث يتحدث عن ارتفاع حصيله ضحايا
الزلزال في سوريا الى ثلاثه الاف واربع
مئه قتيلا حتى الان والعداد لا يتوقف
للاسف جمعه يعني ماذا عن المستلزمات
الاكثر الحاحا على الارض التي رصدتها خلال
يعني جولاتك بالمناطق المتضرره
في جميع المناطق المتضرره الاليات الثقيله
يعني الرجال الذين يمتلكون خبره
في هذه المهام ايضا المعدات الصغيره كلاب
الحراسه الكلاب المدربه في مثل هذه
المهمات كل هذه الامور تفتقدها فرق
الاغاثه سواء في ادلب بحلب او المدن
الاخرى المتضرره يعني هنا يتساوى يعني في
فرق الانقاذ في مناطق النظام مع فرق
الانقاذ في مناطق المعارضه
بغياب الخبرات بغياب المعدات يعني عفوا
جميع المعدات الاخرى الصغيره التي تساعد
في البحث والوصول الى اللاجئين المفترضين
ماذا عن عمل المنظمات المحليه الاغاثيه
يعني كيف تعمل هل قلت لي لم تصل اي
مساعدات اغاثيه حتى الان ولكنها كيف تعمل
فيما بينها
المنظمات او فرق الانقاذ المساعدات لم تصل
الى مناطق المعارضه بينما في مناطق النظام
يعني في مركز مدينه حلب واللاذقيه كان
هناك
فرق قديمه من الجزائر وايضا من لبنان
وايضا كان الجيش الروسي يشارك بعدد من
العناصر في ازاله الانقاض والبحث عن نادين
يعني كان الوضع افضل حتى من ناحيه المعدات
لكن لم تكن كافيه في هذه المناطق ايضا
للوصول الى ناجي بدليل ان العمليات في
اللاذقيه لا تزال مستمره واكثر من نصف
المباني المنهاره لم تصل اليها الفرق
الانقاذ في تلك المناطق هناك حديث عن انه
شاحنات اغاثيه تنتظر وموجوده على معبر باب
الهوى وبعد انقطاع الكهرباء فيه بانه مغلق
هل هذه المعلومات صحيحه
نعم يعني حتى الان لم تدخل اي مساعدات من
معبر باب الهوى نحن نتحدث على المساعدات
الدوليه والمساعدات من المنظمات
الدوليه لدينا معلومات مؤكده لان مفوضيه
شؤون اللاجئين قامت بتجهيز مجموعه من
الشاحنات لادخالها منظمه الصحه العالميه
ايضا لديها يعني النيه بادخال مساعدات يوم
الرد هناك مساعدات من دول عربيه موجوده في
مطار غازي عنتاب ايضا تنتظر يعني الامور
الروتينيه والتنسيق مع الطرف التركي من
المعبر لادخالها ربما غدا تبدا المساعدات
السعوديه بالتدفق عبر معبر باب الهواء ضمن
يعني جناح الامم يعني في تنسيق معلومه من
المتحده ايضا هناك مساعدات من دول اخرى
ايضا تنتظر الدخول
في سياق قرار مجلس الامن الدولي الذي يفوض
يعني الامم المتحده ومنظماتها المختلفه
توصيل
للسوريين عبر هذا المعبر بالتحديد معبر
داب الهواء طيب ما احوال الطرقات في مدن
الشمال السوري التي تاثرت نتيجه هذا
الزلزال وعرقلت الى حد كبير وصول يعني او
التواصل بين المدن هل تم اصلاحها
في الحقيقه يعني هذه الطرق والبنيه
التحتيه بشكل عام متضرر نتيجه سنوات الحرب
جاء زلزال ليفاقم يعني المشاكل في القطاع
في كل القطاعات حتى في البنيه الخدميه لكن
هناك دائما طرق بديله
يتم تسلتها بين المدن المتضرريه لم نسمع
عن مشاكل حقيقيه في ايصال المسيحيه
التواصل بين المدن المتضرره لكن المشكله
الاساسيه كما تعلمين هي في وجود خلافات
بين الفرقاء داخل المشهد السوري يعني بين
مناطق الاداره الذاتيه بين والمعارضه
وايضا بين النظام والمعارضه كان هناك
قطيعه وعدم التواصل لكن اليوم كان هناك
لافته من قبل يعني امر لافت من قبل
الاداره اداه قاموا بارسال 100 شحنه محمله
بمواد
بالوقود الى مناطق حلب ايضا هناك تجهيز من
قبل الاداره الذاتيه لحوالي 15 ش
طبيه اغذيه ادويه بطانيات ستتجه للمره
الاولى الى مناطق غرب سوريا الى مناطق
المعارضه يعني كنا نعرف بان التهديدات
التركيه كانت مستعمره ضد الشمال الشرقي
وكان يعني الفصائل المعارضه تتبول راس
الحربه في هذه العمليه يعني كان هناك
خصومه عسكريه وفرقه سياسيه لكن يبدو الان
العمل الانساني يتفوق في هذه الكارثه على
كل تلك الصراعات والاختلافات نعم حتى
الساعه شكرا جزيلا لك موفد العربيه او
مراسل العربيه فعليا من القامش لجمعه كاش
[موسيقى]
نشعر بسوء شديد كما تعلمون لقد نجونا من
الموت في سوريا جئنا الى تركيا والان هناك
زلزال الناس خائفون وخاصه الاطفال لماذا
لا يمكننا العوده الى المنزل لان جميع
المنازل تهتز اهتزت مره اخرى في ذلك اليوم
لم يكن لدينا خيار سوى المغادره الحرب
يعني
[موسيقى]
علينا يعني نايمين مع خبر
اما الحرب عنا خبر نروح نتخبى
[موسيقى]
نحن نعيش في اسكندر باشا حيي قديم جدا
كانت هناك مشكله في بناياتنا
واحنا دائما معهم قلوبنا معهم وندعي لهم
بصلاتنا والله يصبر قلوبهم على اللي صار
احنا معهم قلبا وقالبا
وان بالدعاء بس والله يثبتهم
والله المستعان منا يا رب السلامه للجميع
نتمنى يا رب
يكون هذا يعني اخر احزان سوريه اخر احزان
تركيا ان شاء الله
ورحمته الله يرحم بينا وبيهم
ينضم الينا جون كلود روكي رئيس مجموعه
الصداقه الفرنسيه التركيه في مجلس الشيوخ
الفرنسي اهلا بك سيد جون كلود يعني
المفوضيه الاوروبيه ورئيستها
الاتحاد الاوروبي يعتزم اقامه واستضافه
مؤتمر للمانحين في مطلع شهر مارس
للمساعدات الدوليه لسوريا وتركيا تقييمك
بالبدايه لعمليه التعهد بارسال المساعدات
ووصولها حتى الساعه
هناك عمل
طوارئ كان ينبغي القيام به في بدايه
الاسبوع لمواجهه هذه الكارثه وقد ارسلت
فرنسا فرق البحث
والانقاذ وكذلك
الكلاب البوليسيه للمساعده في عمليه البحث
والاتحاد الاوروبي سوف يرسل ايضا 200 فرد
مع كلاب بوليسيه لهذا الغرض كما فرنسا
ارسلت مستشفى ميداني هذه هي المساعدات
مساعده الطوارئ الاوليه التي تم ارسالها
ونحن مذهولون لهول هذه الكارثه التي تسببت
بانهيار المباني
والكثير ونحن
نرسل تعازين للرئيس اردوغان ولشعب التركي
ولاسر الضحايا وكذلك
ولقد
ابلغني نظير التركي رئيس مجموعه الصداقه
التركيه الفرنسيه وقد التقيت به في يوليو
في تركيا وهو بصحه جيده لانه في منطقه
تعرض للكثير من الاضرار اذا هذه هي
المساعدات الاوليه ثم نتمنى ان نتمكن من
تقديم المساعده الى تركيا وكذلك سوريا لكن
وضع سوريا اكثر تعقيدا
بسبب الاوضاع التي تسود هناك وينبغي
العبور من خلال او مم المتحده لتقديمها
المساعده وبالتالي فان فرنسا مستعده
للمساعده
هناك مساله مهمه جدا وهي مساله الدمار
الهائل الذي تسبب بهذا الز هذا يتطلب
ارسال الكثير من معدات البحث وهناك الكثير
من البلدان التي
تضررت من هذا الزلزال الذي تسبب بالاف
الضحايا ما دوركم السيده جون كلود كمجموعه
الصداقه الفرنسيه التركيه في ايصال هذه
المساعدات
اولا انا اتصلت مع سفير تركيا
فرنسا كما اتصلت ايضا مع السفير الفرنسي
في تركيا
ليساعدان على تقييم الاحتياجات ونحن ايضا
وقفنا دقيقه صمت في المجلس الشيوخ
حداد على الضحايا نحن من اجل صداقه بين
شعوب وعندما يحتاج شعب للمساعده فدورنا هو
تقديم هذه المساعده اذا نحن
نؤثر ولا نقدم المساعده العينيه ولكن هناك
اتفاق في فرنسا
لتقديم المساعده الى المتضررين وهناك طبعا
شعور عام في فرنسا يؤكد على ضروره مساعد
الشعبين التركي والسوري
بما انك تحدثت عن الشعب السوري ايضا وقلت
بانه الوضع اكثر تعقيدا هناك انتقاد الى
حد كبير لفرنسا ولغيرها من الدول
الاوروبيه والغرب بشكل عام بانه هناك هبه
لمساعده تركيا وارسال المساعدات فيما هناك
تقصير بما يخص سوريا هل الجيوسياسه تلعب
دورا حتى في
المصائب الكبرى
الامر صعب للغايه لانه عندما يكون لديك
دوله تسيطر على كامل التراب الوطني
تستطيعين ان تمر عبر الدوله لتقديم
المساعده اما بالنسبه لسوريا فان الدوله
لا تسيطر على كافه الاراضي فكيف يمكن
تقديم المساعده في المناطق التي لا تخضع
لسيطره في الحكومه وهذا لا يتحقق الا عبر
الامم المتحده وبالتالي فان المساعد
لسوريا معقده للغايه عكس تركيا التي يمكن
تقديم المساعده لها دون ايه عراقيل
همم تحدثت عن تطلعك لدور اكبر للامم
المتحده بالمساعده بايصال الاغاثه ان كان
لتركيا او لسوريا كيف ذلك عبر اي مسارات
اي ممرات
وخاصه بانه الان ثلاثه ايام على هذا
الزلزال هل تعولون على المرحله اللاحقه
ربما مرحله اعاده الاعمار
تمناه ولكن
الدوله يمكن ان تتحرك بسرعه اكبر من
الاتحاد الاوروبي والامم المتحده والمتحده
عباره عن اله بطيئه وفرنسا قررت ارسال فرق
البحث
والمساعده
وقد تم ذلك بسرعه ولكن عندما نلجا الى
الاتحاد الاوروبي او الامم المتحده فان
الامر صعب وهذا ينطبق على المساعده التي
تقدم الى تركيا وسوريا على حد
سواب رئيس التركي تحدث عن انه فرق الانقاذ
التي وصلت الى تركيا هي من 60 دوله وتجاوز
عددها ال 21
كيف تقيمون هذه يعني هذه المساعده الدوليه
الكبيره
جيد ان تتضامن الدول فيما بينها واعتقد ان
هناك دول لديها امكانات اكثر من غيرها
وبالتالي ينبغي على هذه الدول ان تساهم في
جهود اعاده الاعمار وقبل ذلك ان تقدم
المساعده للبلد المتضرر اما بالنسبه
لمجموعه الصداقه الفرنسيه التركيه فهذه
المجموعه تركز على الشعوب والحكومات
موجوده وهي موجوده بطريقه شرعيه ولكن نحن
في اوروبا نحاول ان نقرب
الاعضاء المنتخبين في فرنسا مع نظرائهم
الاتراك ومن خلال هذه القناه نحاول ان
نؤثر على الاوضاع السائده شكرا جزيلا لك
اذا من باريس جون كلود روكي رئيس مجموعه
الصداقه الفرنسيه التركيه في مجلس الشيوخ
الفرنسي
وساري طيب عم تحكي
[موسيقى]
الصبر يا رب الصبر بس والله عم توجع كتير
لا تحرك ايدك لا تحرك ايدك
حاول تسحبها كتير
بتوجعني
[موسيقى]
الله يرحمه
انا فاقد بنتي ولا اثنين
عمي ابو مهدي
قلبي كل الجلي صار كل شي صار فيا ما كنت
مفكر
والله ربنا يصبرهم على اللي حصل اللي حصل
كان كان صعب محدش اي حد يقدر يستحمله او
يعدي به بس الحمد لله هم قدها وقدود يعني
مره تانيه وربنا يصبرهم على اللي حصل
والله الموضوع صعب جدا هو الحقيقه مش ضامن
مع الشعب السوري ولا التركي ولا اللبناني
هو تضامن مع الانسانيه دي حاجه بتاعه ربنا
طبعا ما حدش في ايده حاجه بس لازم
ندعمهم في خاصه في فصل الشتاء لان الجو
برد طبعا جدا التعازي ليهم من قلب بجد
الحاره انا تفاجات بالموضوع لما صحيت بدري
الصبح على هزه ارضيه ما بالك ان دوله
مصريه او الدوله المصريه نفسها حسيت
بتوابع الزلزال دوت فالله يكون في عونه
بجد من اللي حصل معاهم
وينضم الينا من الحدود السوريه التركيه
الصحفي خالد ابو المجد اهلا بك سيد خالد
يعني اداره معبر باب الهوى بالتصريح
للعربيه تحدثت انه الجانب التركي وعد بفتح
المعبر لكن ذلك لم يحدث حتى اللحظه ما
الاسباب التي تعطى ما المبررات في ظل هذه
الازمه الانسانيه الكبرى التي يعانيها
البلدين
نعم طبعا كما ذكرتي اداره معبر باب الهوى
اعلنت بان لم يدخل اي شيء من الاراضي
التركيه الى الداخل السوري وكذلك لم تدخل
اي مساعدات سواء كانت امميه او دوليه الى
هذه المناطق حتى الان السوريين السوريين
ينتظرون بفارغ الصبر اي مساعده دوليه ولو
تاخرت هذه المساعده طبعا كل ساعه تتاخر
فيها هذه المساعدات الدوليه المطلوبه
والمطلوب عاجلا هي الاليات الثقيله لانقاذ
ما يمكن انقاذه كل ساعه تاخر يعني مزيدا
من الاشخاص الذين يتوفون تحت هذه الانقاض
انقاض الزلزال الذي دمر مساحات واسعه من
المناطق في ريف حلب طبعا لو سمحتي لي
ساذكر بان بعض المناطق التي دمرت بشكل
كبير مناطق في منطقه جنديرس احياء بالكامل
ما تزال تحت المئات تحت الانقاذ
التخوف الكبير بالنسبه للدفاع المدني
وبالنسبه للاهالي هو طول الوقت كل كل هذه
المده التي يتم التاخر فيها بانقاذ
المدنيين هي يعني وفاه جديده اليوم فرح
كثير من الناس بسبب ان عوائلهم وصلوا
اليها وانقذوهم انقذوا اعداد كبيره الدفاع
المدني في الداخل السوري انقذوا النساء
واطفال لكن
التاخر الان اصبح اكثر من 60 او 70 ساعه
الناس تحت الانقاد هذا الشيء يعرض الاشخاص
الذين هم تحت الانقاض الى الموت طبعا لو
عدنا ايضا الى ما هو المطلوب وهل
المساعدات الدوليه تصل تصل الى داخل
السوري اودا انوه بان يعني قضيه ساتكلم
بها احد الاصدقاء في الجزائر تكلم مع احد
الاصدقاء وقال له نحن ارسلنا طواقم طبيه
لكم لم تصل وما شابه اود ان اؤكد على
العربيه الان ان ما يقدم من مساعدات دوليه
تاتي الى النظام السوري هي لا تاتي بالفعل
الى مناطق
المناطق المعارضه المناطق الخارجه عن
سيطره قوات النظام لانه بالفعل قوات
النظام هي التي فعلت مثل هذا الزلزال على
بدا الماضيه وقتلت السوريين فكيف بهم
لا يوجد اي جهه حكوميه في هذه المناطق ولم
تصل اي مساعدات من الدول ان كان العربيه
او حتى الغربيه التي قدمت لسوريا الى
المناطق الخاضعه للمعارضه التركيه
لسيطرتها
من هم من يفترض ان يكونوا هم المسؤولين
الرسميين او السياسيين عن هذه المنطقه
للتواصل مع الدول هو الائتلاف الحكومه
المؤقته لكن نقولها بصراحه هم ليسوا على
قدر المسؤوليه ابدا من يقود هذه المرحله
السيد خالد الان يعني نتحدث عن امور اسمى
بكثير عنه ليس عن السياسه لا نريد ان ندخل
بزواريب السياسه بل الاوضاع الانسانيه
وعليه اودن اسال عن المعابر البديله يعني
العديد من المحللين تحدثوا بانه غير معبر
بابل هواه هناك معابر اخرى في جرابلس هناك
بمعبر باب السلامه لماذا لا يتم فتح هذه
المعابر اللي في منها معبر باب السلام وهو
تحت سيطره الاتراك
انا كنت ساتكلم بهذا الموضوع ميدانيا وليس
سياسيا اقول بان من المفترض ان يتواصلوا
وهم لا احد يتواصلوا ولا احد يعلم حتى
السوريين انفسهم لا نعلم لماذا لا تفتح
هذه المعابر لماذا لا تدخل من يدير هذه
العمليه هم الدفاع المدني وهو من المفترض
يعني ان يتواصل الجميع الدفاع المدني
والفرقه الانقاذ والناشطين تواصلوا الجميع
يقول بان المعابر مفتوحه لكن لا تصل لم
تصل اي مساعدات الجميع يقول بان المعابره
مفتوحه لم تصل الى مساعدات من تركيا لم
تصل اي مساعدات وكذلك المناطق النظام لم
تصل وغير متوقع ان تصل هذه المساعدات نعم
سيد خالد يعني
الاغلبيه سكان المناطق مناطق الشمال
السوري المتاخمه للحدود السوريه التركيه
كانوا يعتمدون بشكل كبير على الاغذيه على
المساعدات الطبيه كل ذلك من الجانب التركي
الان ماذا يفعلون
نعم كل المنفس بالنسبه للمناطق الشمال
سوريا هي هي
المعابر الحدوديه مع تركيا ما يحصل الان
بان تركيا الان منشغله ايضا بكارثه
انسانيه
متواجده على الحدود في كل من منطقه مرعش
وانطاكيا ومناطق هاتاي المناطق الملاصقه
للحدود السوريه التركيه ما هو المطلوب
اليوم بالنسبه للسوريين هو ليس فتح
المعابر المعابر مفتوحه بل ادخال هذه
الطواقم وكذلك تواصل الطواقم سواء كانت
العربيه والاماميه مع تركيا ومع الدخل
السوري لادخالهم الى الداخل السوري من هو
يقف عائق صراحه نحن حتى الان لم يصلنا بان
هناك دفعه مثلا دخل تريد الدخول لم تدخل
اكثر ما وصلنا بان هناك الدفعات امميه من
منقذين وكذلك من متدربين يودون الدخول
للداخل السوري لكن هناك تحذيرات خطره
بالنسبه لهم بانه من سيضمن حياتكم من
سيحميكم كيف سيتم التعاون معكم اذا دخلتم
يعني وبالامكانيات التي لدينا
كشعب او كنشطين يعني ان شاء الله ليست
هناك اي مخاطر على حياه هؤلاء الاشخاص
سواء كانوا من دفعات عربيه وامميه سيدخلون
الداخل السوري وهذا ما نستطيع ان نقوله
فقط ليست لدينا ايضا نحن كلاشتين حتى نحن
الاشخاص
بانفسهم ليست لدينا ضمانات قوات النظام لن
احول موضوع سياسيا لكن يعني ما هي المخاوف
التي تتخوف منها البتات العربيه او
الدوليه طبعا المستشفىات الميدانيه
سيد خالد ماذا عن المستشفيات الميدانيه
بالمدن الرئيسيه
المتضرره يعني ما احوالها هل وصلت الى
طاقتها الاستيعابيه القصوى هي اصلا كانت
تعاني من نقص حاد بالادويه حتى يعني
الكثير من الناس يقولون حتى الادويه
العاديه لم تكن متواجده اصلا قبل هذا
الزلزال
صحيح تماما المناطق الخارج عن سيطره قوات
النظام هي بالاساس مناطق يعني لا توجد
فيها بنيه تحتيه صالحه بشكل تام فما بالك
في هذه الحاله تتعرض لازمه كبيره طبعا
المشافي تكاد ان تكون اغلقت بسبب مغلقه
يعني امتلات بسبب عدد كبير من الحالات
التي وصلت اليها بشكل سريع هذا الامر دفع
اصحاب المشافي الخاصه لفتح ابوابهم
بالمجان كثير من المشايخ فتحت ابوابها
بالمجان لاستقبال عدد كبير من الحالات
هناك حالات كبيره اعداد كبيره جدا وصلت
الى المشافي وكذلك الطواقم الطبيه هي
قريبه بشكل كبير من اماكن انتشار الضحايا
وكذلك استنفرت
فرق الاسعاف اود ان اقول بان هناك جهود
كبيره وحثيثه بالنسبه الان ما يفعله
السوريين هو تضميط جراحهم بانفسهم هذه
حقيقه الواقع تماما السوريين انفسهم هم من
ينقذون انفسهم هناك اعداد الاطباء من
الممرضين خالد وانت تتحدث المركز الوطني
السوري لرصد الزلازل تحدث عن هزه ارضيه
بقوه 4.3 درجه على مقياس ريخطر على الحدود
السوريه اللبنانيه هل شعرت بها
نحن لم تتوقف عندنا الارتدادات منذ
اللحظات الاولى للزلزال هذا هذا هذه الهزه
التي ذكرت
وشعر بها شعر بها الاهالي في لبنان وفي
سوريا هي تقريبا اصبحت بالنسبه للسوريين
هي شيء اعتيادي والسبب بان هناك احصيه
تقريبا اكثر من 400 ارتداد من جراء
الزلزاليه لم تتوقف حيث تتواجد انت على
الحدود السوريه التركيه
ابدا لم تتوقف لا في شمال سوريا ولا في
جنوب تركيا لم تتوقف هذه الارتدادات وكما
ذكرت لك تقريبا اكثر من 400 ارتداد وصل
الى الى شمال سوريا ويعني اصبحت لن اقول
اعتياديه بمعنى الكلمه لكن اصبحت لم تخيف
الاهالي طبعا لو سمحتي ايضا هناك نقطه
مهمه كثيرا بان المدنيين اليوم يعني هم
بين خيارين احلاهما مر من يقف من المدنيين
من هو متواجد من المدنيين في داخل المنازل
هناك خطر على حياته لان هناك
يعني منازل مصدعه من الجراء الاول او
المناطق بالاساس هي من كثره القصف الذي
تعرضت له هذه المناطق فهي مباني الى
السقوط ومن لا يريد البقاء في منزله يريد
الخروج هو وعائلته يعني اكثر ربما امنا
الى الشوارع بروده الطقس لن تساعد الاهالي
اليوم درجه الحراره ناقص اثنين او اربعه
الارض قارص جدا وكذلك الامطار ليله
البارحه اعاقت
فرق من مساعدات المدنيين وكذلك الان
الاهالي يفترشون الحدائق والمساجد هربا من
ربما زلازل اخرى شكرا جزيلا لك من الحدود
السوريه التركيه الصحه في خالد ابو المجد
الهزات الارتداديه سلسله من الزلازل تحدث
بعض الصدمه الرئيسيه الاكبر على الصدع بين
الصفائح التكتونيه تحدث بالقرب من الصدع
بحسب العلماء حيث حدثت الصدمه الرئيسيه هي
جزء من عمليه اعاده التعديل بعد الانزلاق
الرئيسي في الصدع بين الصفائح
تنتج عن التغيير المفاجئ في الاجهاد الذي
يحدث داخل وبين الصخور ليس لها عدد محدد
الا ان تواترها ينخفض مع الوقت تستمر حتى
ايام او اشهر او سنوات بعد الهزه الاساسيه
تم تسجيل اقوى هزه ارتداديه بعد الزلزال
الذي ضرب تركيا وسوريا على انها زلزال
بقوه 7.5 درجه وتلتها مئات الهزات
الارتداديه في المنطقه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اذا مراسله العربيه تؤكد الخبر الذي
اوردناه عن هزه ارضيه شعر بها سكان الحدود
السوريه اللبنانيه بقوه 4.2 درجه وهي
تحديدا بجنوب الهرمل الهرمل هي منطقه
حدوديه بالبقاع الشمالي
الهرمل من الناحيه اللبنانيه والقصير من
الناحيه الحدود السوريه نتابع بما يخص
تركي حيث تمكنت فرق لانقاذ التركيه في
ولايه هاتاي من انقاذ رضيع حديث الولاده
بعد ان بقي تحت الانقاذ لاكثر من خمسين
ساعه
[موسيقى]
ازيك
زلزال تركيا وسوريا عبث كما يشاء
بالممتلكات والارواح وترك خلفه حطاما
مكدسا لكن الاكثر من ذلك ترك جروحا غائره
من الالم لكل من عاش هذا الكابوس الحقيقي
ارقام الوفيات مفاتيح تتزايد وحجم الخراب
والدمار يتسع شيئا فشيئا لكن ماذا عن حجم
الالم الذي لا يقاس بالارقام والاحصائيات
يومان فقط على مرور الزلزال كانا كافيين
لرصد مئات المشاهد المؤلمه والقصص الحزينه
التي ستبقى محفوره في الذاكره الاطفال
لوحدهم يحتلوا المساحه الاكبر من الحزن في
هذه الماساه فهل هناك اكثر حزنا من ان
تفقد طفله كل افراد عائلتها خلال 60 ثانيه
فقط او ان تحرم رضيعه حديثه الولاده من
دفء حضن امها التي رحلت تحت الانقاض كل
الكارثه شربوا من نفس الكاس المره وان
اختلفت مالاتهم النجاه لا تعفي من الالم
فهناك من اتعبه ترقب سماع خبر عن مصير
اهله العالقين
اما اخرون فلم يجدوا سوى سياراتهم العتيقه
للاحتماء من البرد بعدما لم يعد لهم ماوى
بينما التحف ناجون العراء بعدما انهارت
اسقف كانت تقيهم برد الشتاء القارس حتى
الفرحه بالنجاه كانت مؤلمه مع هول الصدمه
كثيرون لم يجدوا سوى الدموع والصراخ
للتعبير عنها بل حتى هناك من لم يسعد حقا
بنجاته وكيف يفعل وقد سرق زلزال اعزاء ما
لديه
وسامه الذهبي العربيه
ادعي لي خيو سامحني
انت يعني
وفوقه حجار كتير منتفخيت وكثير عم توجعني
طيب عم تحكي
[موسيقى]
الصبر يا رب الصبر بس والله عم توجعكتي لا
تحرك ايدك لا تحرك ايدك
احاول تسحب
توجعني
انضم الينا من غازي عنتاب هاتفيا
ابو لوز اهلا بك غسان يعني الى متى ستستمر
عمليات الاغاثه تحديدا بغازي عنتاب
طبيعه الحال راويه الوضع صعب جدا في غازي
عنتاب تحديدا في بلده الاصلاحيه نتحدث عن
بلده 50% من المباني منهاره تماما وايضا
هناك المئات من المباني
ايله لسقوط باي لحظه مباني متصدعه ومتشققه
وكما كان يتحدث ضيفك قبل قليل عن الهزات
الارتداديه سلطات التركيه تحدثت عن 790 هز
ارتداديه تم رصدها من بعد
الزلازل التي ضربت الزلزلين اللذين ضربا
تركيا يوم الاثنين الماضي
ستستمر وتتواصل عمليات الاغاثه والانقاذ
والمساعدات
هناك اعداد كبيره من المواطنين المنكوبين
الذين يعني باتوا بلا ماوى في لحظه الان
هناك عشرات الاف الخيم يتم توزيعها ايضا
هناك مراكز الايواء التي يتم نقل
المنكوبين اليها وايضا يتم اجلاء هؤلاء
اعداد كبيره ايضا من هؤلاء الى مدن اخرى
وولايات اخرى عبر الخطوط الجويه التركيه
وحتى هناك طائرات رئاسيه تم تخصيص طائرتين
رئاسيتين لنقل
ماذا عن على المستشفيات الميدانيه
والتعامل العاجل مع الحالات التي تخرج حيه
من تحت الانقاد
بالفعل هناك عشرات من المستشفيات
الميدانيه تم انشائها في المدن العشر
المنكوبه في جنوب تركيا ويتم تعامل مع
الاصابات
وحالات
التي تعرضت لاصابات خلال هذا الزلزال
وايضا يتم التعامل مع
المواطنين الذين هم بحاجه الى
الطبيه بحاجه الى علاجات
هناك يعني مجتمع باكمله راويه
بحاجه الى كافه انواع المساعدات بما فيها
المساعدات الطبيه وايضا هناك العيادات
المتنقله وهناك ايضا الالاف من الاطقم
الطبيه قد وصلوا الى هذه المناطق والاطباء
وبالتالي هناك ضغط كبير على الجميع
القطاعات سواء كانت قطاعات الاغاثه او
القطاعات الصحيه او الانسانيه هناك ضغط
كبير عليها بسبب الكارثه التي لحقت
بالبلاد نتيجه الزلزال ما زالت عمليات
الانقاذ مستمره راويه هناك يعني كان خبرا
لافته لافتا تناقلته وسائل اعلام محليه عن
نقل 16 طفلا الى ولايه انقره
لا يعرف من هم ذويهم فتم نقلهم هناك الى
حين التعرف على هويتهم وعلى اهاليهم فهذا
يعني جزء من الماساه التي تعيش البلاد
هناك وفيات وهناك ايضا
نعم عن هذه النقطه التعرف على الجثث وهي
مرحله صعبه كان اداره الكوارث والطوارئ
التركيه تحدثت بانه الجافه مين التي لا
يتم التعرف على اصحابها ستدفن بعد 24 ساعه
من انتشالها
نعم نعم
[موسيقى]
يعني في كثير من الاحيان يتم التعرف على
الجثث ويتم دفنها مباشره وامن الجثه
الاخرى التي لا يتم التعرف عليها كما اشرت
يتم دفنه بعد 24 ساعه لكن بعد اخذ عينه من
الحمض النووي حتى ترضيعه هذه الجثث ماساه
كبيره راويه هناك فرق انقاذ ما زالت تواصل
العمليات السلطات تؤكد بانها ستقوم بتسريع
عمليات ازاله الانقاذ
ولن تترك احد في ان تترك احد وحيدا في هذا
الظرف الاستثنائي ايضا كان هناك يعني حديث
ان بان الرئيس اردوغان وعد بان يكون هناك
وحدات سكانيه
للمتضررين كما ايضا قال ان هناك مبالغ
ماليه تصرف للاسر المتضرره في البلاد هناك
توقعات بان يعني تصل تكاليف هذه الكارثه
الى عشرات المليارات وبالتالي الوضع يعني
صعب على جميع النواحي
وايضا يعني الزلزال وقع في ظل ظروف جويه
صعبه جدا وسيئه جدا وهذا ما يزيد من
التحدي امام السلطات وايضا من الصعوبه على
المنكوبين والذين فقدوا مساكنهم ومبانيهم
وبالتالي هم الان في مراكز ايواءهم بحاجه
الى مساعدات عجله عن مراكز الايواء غسان
تحدثت عن انه عداد
القتلى يرتفع بشكل كبير بالساعات الاخيره
هل يرجع ذلك ربما الى طواقم الانقاذ
الدوليه التي وصلت باعداد كبيره
والمساعدات يعني
انتشال هذه الجثث والتعرف عليها
نعم بالفعل راويه يعني ساهمت تلك الطواقم
الدوليه التي وصلت في مساعده واسناد فرق
الانقاذ وهيئه الكوارث والطوارئ وايضا
الاليات التي بدات تصل الى المناطق
الجنوبيه تعلمين يعني الكارثه وقعت في
جنوب البلاد
والمساعدات بدات يعني
تتدفق باتجاه المناطق الجنوبيه تحديدا
فيما يتعلق بالاليات الثقيله والكبيره
والضخمه للتعامل مع هذه المباني المنهاره
يعني انت تتحدثين عن مباني تتالف من خمس
طوابق واكثر في بعض الاحيان تصل الى عشره
طوابق وخمسه عشر طابقا وربما اكثر من ذلك
فبالتالي مثل هذه المباني وهذا
واضح يحتاج الى اليات ثقيله وكبيره جدا
حتى تتعامل مع هذه
الانقاض الكبيره وهي بالاصنان يتم التعامل
معها بشكل دقيق جدا وبحرص كبير جدا حتى
يحافظوا قدر الامكان على حياه العالقين
وان كان هناك ناجين تحت الانقاض وهي عمليه
معقده ومضنيه جدا جدا راويه تتواصل في
ساعات الليل وساعات النهار وبالتالي هذه
العمليات المتواصله والمساعدات التي تصل
يعني الاسناد الذي يصل من الدول الاخرى
الى تركيا ساهم بالفعل يعني
مساعده ما يمكن مساعدته وانقاذ ما يمكن
انقاذه وبالتالي هذا ما يفسر ايضا
ارتفاع عدد القتلى وايضا عامل الوقت راويه
يؤثر بشكل كبير يعني نحن في اليوم الثالث
من
الزلزال من وقت ما ضرب الزلزال وبالتالي
الان فرق الانقاذ امام تحدي كبير وهو عامل
الوقت هم الوقت يلعب دوران كبيرا اعذرني
غسان على المقاطعه طبعا سنكون معك بنشرات
لاحقه في اطار هذه التغطيه المفتوحه
لزلزال تركيا وسوريا شكرا جزيلا لك حتى
الساعه